44 and looking better than ever before  David Beckham rang in his 44th year with  a perfect celebration surrounded by his  wife and kids here's the famil cozied up  together at David's birthday dinner the  kiddos look so grown up  that's Romeo on the left next to mom  Victoria David has his arm around crews  who's sitting next to big bro Brooklyn  and on the right there's daddy's little  girl Harper  I have no power with that little girl no  power to even it shared this sweet snap  with Harper at dinner to his insta story  along with this selfie with Cruz and  this portrait of all three of his boys  Victoria also posted this tribute to her  hubby on his special day writing you are  our everything we love you so much I'm  so lucky that we are such a close family  and David is such a great husband such a  great dad and the most incredible  business partner that anybody could ever  want well he really supports me in what  I do  [Music]